yeah one thing that surprised me on the
road trip was you you you when you're
constantly on the air sometimes you go
to a point it's open roads can't nothing
to block the signal and it just like
loses connection yeah and then you go in
like a mile long tunnel and it's just
like perfect signal all the way through
and I'm like what it's so random man how
does this work I should know because I'm
an electronic engineer but I'm just like
how are we having signal right now it's
cell phone towers really close and also
depends on which provider they are
because which Sims I have right but I
have multiple different teams that do
that should cover everything but yeah it
really depends um certain areas should
have just nothing yeah but the first day
was pretty tough I think there was not a
lot on a waju surprisingly
um and the third day we did which Grant
joined us before we did uh the golf golf
we don't do driving range driving range
and I like this was the first time I'd
been on a driving range or like picked
up a golf club since I was I think like
18 17. it's so much I told you oh I've
been telling you boys
yeah so yeah we did that and we did a
competition so you could hit it the
furthest yeah I won you won you won I
got one very good shot
dude it was so fun I want to go driving
range more yeah and then we did
um what else we do that day I forgot uh
we did a sound surfing yeah we're in San
serving totally yeah that was fun we
went back to the uh ghost town that is
totally uh I drove past the industrial
area I'm like don't look at that don't
look at that all right look at the Sand
Dunes yeah which uh I think looked even
more like the the weather conditions
what looked even better than when we
went there on our road trip special
cameras we were using for this live
stream were better than the cameras we
filmed the road trip fashion right so it
looks like it looks better live which is
insane yeah and I didn't I also didn't
know if totally was gonna have internet
yeah but yeah totally is great internet
as well so fun fact there you go yeah I
don't know so we were in the looks
insane on the stream we're just in the
in the middle of a desert streaming yeah
it's just like what what
we're going down these Hills and it
looks great yeah dude it like it looks
so underwhelming on camera but it was
kind of scary going down these because
you're going pretty fast and sand I mean
I didn't fall so I can't yeah oh it
probably hurts way I imagine you fell on
your wrist right I fell on my wrist once
okay so I'll say it right now sand
surfing I was kind of mad it was kind of
it was kind of a Mad experience yeah
because you you you just go down and you
can't do Hills that are super crazy
because I guess if you get too fast yeah
falling would be pretty and you can't
you can't turn either we weren't given
any instructions so how I described it
um Sansa thing was basically felt like a
tutorial level for snowboarding because
I I remember with bigger consequences
yeah basically you fall it hurts a
little bit more
um but essentially you go up to the hill
and uh I remember we had an instructor
there and I Was preparing myself for the
instructions to start and the
instructions were uh so don't fall yeah
yeah that was like don't on a turn
you're just going straight just uh don't
fall and that was the instructions and
it was like okay go you might as well
have just like been on a sled then at
that point actually he told us before we
started he was like if you think this is
going to be like snowboarding you're
gonna fail yeah and I was and I was like
what how can be it wasn't that hard
actually he was he was Captain yeah he's
like snowboarding yeah um you just have
to balance the same way yeah yeah but
also all he said was um he'll said it
might be too hard so he brought sleds as
well so which was kind of worrying so I
was like oh that's not good too hard is
someone gonna hurt themselves so he just
gave us a helmet he said bend your knees
and then just go that was all yep wow he
pushed us yeah yeah and then he goes oh
by the way 10 year olds can do this
um but yeah I mean it was kind of it was
like I said it was kind of like
snowboarding except you couldn't do
anything but go straight so essentially
you just kind of had to learn how to
balance going down a hill pretty fast
and I'd forgotten like it's been a while
since the last snowboarded and I'd
forgotten basically everything I got
told when I first started snowboarding
because I remember going somewhere
snowboarding for the first time with the
boys and the first thing they told me
was when you fall don't put your hands
out you gotta put your hands in and I'd
for some reason my mind was just like
sounds different Sans totally I'll go
straight through it yeah so that is
totally different than snow I don't I
don't have to worry about sand uh and I
the first time I felt I put my hand out
and it wasn't even like that big of a
four I was going nowhere near as fast as
I was going when I was like snowboarding
but I just had like a little bit and uh
my wrist hit my wrists and I was you
that I had that immediate moment where I
was like oh that that felt bad that felt
bad I was like okay it's not broken I
might have sprained it luckily I didn't
sprain it but I had a big wake-up call
very very fast but uh falling on Sand uh
sand surfing you're the full you might
not be as hard as snowboarding but the
four definitely hurts more and uh
luckily I wasn't the one who ate the
most [__] probably died of stuff oh my
God I felt so bad yeah Titus ever he he
would nail it going down and the moment
like the hill went from this to kind of
like this yeah yeah just kind of lost
his balance every time and face planted
I felt so bad for him he just kept
getting beaten up Jesus yeah he had a
few holes that looked pretty painful oh
my God but he powered through it
it was fun but it was kind of like it
was very much like oh that's it yeah
like it was like oh that's what we could
do yeah like I feel like it sucks I mean
it was it was definitely I think it was
still like a fun place to check out and
it I think it's like we we hit like
every kind of scenery like we went from
like beautiful stunning green Islands to
snow to Desert yeah back to Osaka it was
kind of like it covered everything and
then um we did that and then we played
video not video games we played games in
the RV which is really fun actually yeah
break the ice is a great game yeah you
kind of introduced me to break the ice
we played this game no it's like a
little thing where it's like a penguin
in the middle and a bunch of hexagons
yeah
good it's such a good game when
everyone's kind of hype and ready and
you have like punishments and yeah it
was so good it's kind of like that mini
game from four guys the one with the
hexagons except you have to hit them
yeah but you you have to hit them such a
good game there's so many good clips
from it and it was just a fun it was
such a good fun yeah board game I think
as as much as like you guys did these
like amazing things on the RV strip uh I
think my favorite clip to be both out of
it was when you asked didus when Milos
scripted that's perfect it was because
he was so sincere about it as I was like
what's my location
[Music]
thank you to the guy in Australia who
got asked with that because that's that
that one that trained us to get someone
else it's our new favorite yeah it's my
new favorite as a Southeast Asian that's
my new favorite because we we [__]
love Milo in Southeast Asia you know
that's that's our chocolate of choice
yeah you don't like it no no oh yeah I
said oh yeah oh no now your screen just
went oh yeah and I was like what
yeah yeah is it much better than Nesquik
or is it oh hell yeah oh yeah yeah oh
yeah oh yeah Australia's the same we
[__] love our mileage yeah it's so
good there's so it was good it seems
like there was a lot of good Clips in
the car and you know it's more of a
podcast written in the car and there's
back to the activities yeah yeah yeah
the board games were really fun that was
one of my favorite aspects of it yeah
just playing playing dumbled games and
just just everyone everyone has their
own rules to everything
Django it's just like what are the rules
of Jenga because we just kind of like
made it up as we go there's like a
million the Only Rule that was sacred
was top three layers can't touch top yes
that's the only sacred touch you have to
move it was the one yeah you have to use
one hand only right that's another one
but I don't know if it's an official
rule I swear people just make up rules
for Jenga be like yeah let's just make
it a billion times harder than it
actually is supposed to be yeah like
you're like we had we had this one
moment where I swear this isn't allowed
but we have to run with the one hand
thing yeah and Connor uses one hand to
basically change the entire structural
Integrity of this Tower it was it went
from like a Jenga Tower to the Leaning
Tower of Pisa and he was just like he
was just like it I was getting it out my
finger while kind of holding the rest of
them
so illegal right now because it was like
what sucked is that we were like four
turns in and this one block wouldn't
move that's the point I was like are we
really gonna end this game in four turns
that's so bad yeah but how is that any
different to like grabbing with one and
then using your other hand to just hold
the entire thing in place that's right I
mean like honestly Django should always
get to that point in my mind where like
you holding it makes no difference to
like like if I like it gets to the point
where me holding it you're gonna make it
worse you know yeah because it gets so
[__] the tower it's like yeah holding
it is actually a disadvantage I don't
know that's just me maybe I'm maybe I'm
I'm trolling it wrong but that's all
rules and it was like it was like
snowing outside and we had the we had
the because the connection was kind of
mad we had like the starlink on a table
outside of the van and connected to this
this generator and then we're just using
that internet and that was like saving
the stream way better because we again
we were in the middle of nowhere again
um and that saved it and then the last
day we did uh Airsoft so that was
survival so much fun yeah that was my
first time Airsoft doing it yeah me too
that that lived up to the hype yeah I
want to go again now like it was fun I I
actually I think I found it funner than
paintballing yeah well it hurts a little
less it hurts a little less and the guns
just look cooler as well yeah
you know really like reloading uh uh
airsoft gun actually feels like you know
more similar to reloading a real gun
rather than just [__] like yeah
pouring a bunch of uh paintballs into
into the gun yeah that was fun we did we
were like again we had to like move the
starlink around to get into that uh
because the bitrate was terrible there
it was such a bad internet because
obviously it's an airsoft field it's in
the middle of nowhere right yeah um shot
on the neck three times oh yeah it looks
like I got bitten by a vampire actually
hey you guys said it hurts less than a
paintball it does hurt less I mean this
one [__] hurt this one yeah I was
about to say like the scars there's
there's one red dot on his forehead that
I I uh that I did yeah yeah
unfortunately shot
yeah
most of them are fine they're like
little stings but like yeah if you get
hit in the head or the neck I feel like
that's where it [__] my legs hurt so
much because we we're in a course where
it was just like a bunch of like parts
cars you know it's like the car park
kind of area first thing daughter says
was like Oh I thought these were real
cars so I tried not to like shoot them
and then like they had broken windows
but unfortunately do you remember
I don't believe you said the average car
park in Maine
average Ohio car block right
um but yeah like unfortunately being
tall was a huge disadvantage in this one
because uh if I just like poked if I
just poked my head out I would instantly
get a headshot it was actually really
easy to be quite accurate on the uh on
the airsoft I was like surprisingly
accurate because it's cool yeah because
I got a few headshots from like a
distance you got so many shots from the
distance as well I got a lot of
headshots for instance especially on
dieters yes that's an FPS player yeah
FPS player Advantage because I realized
like when you're aiming it like
obviously I'm not like cracked at aiming
airsoft's ever played it but like if you
shoot and unlike paintball the airsoft
bullet always goes the exact same like
trajectory unless yeah so all you do is
like and you can see where it's going
then just like readjusting and then you
can pretty much get it so that like if
they poke their head at all you can just
get there yeah right right yeah and you
can just slightly adjust so I just kept
doing that and I kept getting data set I
felt so bad I tried them so many times
um next time I see him his face is just
going to be like [__] well luckily he
was running already he was running a
thick hat so like his face was totally
covered yeah uh he had the one that
covered his ears too so it was like he
was oh he was fine he was ready
yeah it was really fun and we had like
uh unfortunately the camera had to go
around with us and he would get shot
sometimes because he was just going
around it was it looked awesome it
looked like an FPS yeah and again it was
like great quality like 4K in the middle
of nowhere yeah and then we changed povs
where he there was an area where you
could go above and you could look down
oh wow the camera so it was like it was
kind of like uh oh like bird eye view of
the whole yeah wait no clipping yeah
yeah it was like such a cool stream and
we had such fun with it and yeah we we
were great we had this one game where I
just could not find Pete and Pete just
Pete clipped into another map right
there there was like this indoor this
this indoor stage right that was like
very like very narrow corridors and Pete
spent like whole five minutes in this
outdoor map and he didn't even know he
was in a different room he didn't know
he was in a different area
um but yeah like it it hurts a lot less
than people like paintball I feel like
you can still very like even if you're
wearing like thick clothes you can still
kind of feel it oh yeah
um this one unless you get shot like
directly on the skin it doesn't it it
doesn't really hurt that much yeah
um have you been painting on
paintballing before I've been
paintballing before I've never been
airsofting right and I've been shot
directly with a paintball before and it
sounds like a very Aussie thing yeah
yeah yeah as punished as punishment for
whoever got the least amount of points
you have to get shot directly in the
stomach for the paintball and I had that
a couple of times and I was left with
like literal holes in my stomaches you
get from paintballing oh it hurts so
much holy [__] yeah paintballing feels
more like you're just trying to avoid
getting killed and yeah uh Airsoft felt
more kind of because it didn't hurt as
much you kind of felt more fun yeah yeah
exactly uh but yeah I mean I do enjoy
the adrenaline aspect of paintball where
you're like I just don't want to get
shot yeah paintball is like valorant and
uh Airsoft is more like cod I would say
yeah yeah because because you know you
do not want to get shot in paintball you
know yeah you're like well it's one show
kill if I'm getting chill I'm [__]
out man but with airsoft you're like I
can I can run I can run this I can run
and go don't do circles
yeah you would just run around corners
because you knew that if you got shot it
wasn't like the end of the world yeah
yeah other people once like well I'm
gonna have a bruise if I get shot yeah I
have to actually like this thing's gonna
go I have to think about where I think
what's happening
um man yeah no I'm such a fan of extreme
then we just drove back and ended it and
that was like 40 hours of streaming hell
yeah how's it being live for like that
long
um it's it's okay for me uh I mean he's
done sabbathons before so yeah I'm okay
with it but like man doing it and
driving is tough like driving is taxing
mentally anyway and then trying to also
be like good like conversing while
driving is hard yeah which is why it's
great to have uh you know you and Pete
and died yeah the real question was how
was it for you because you're probably
not used to that I was I was actually
like pretty fine with it uh you've
gotten really good at it I I think after
the uh 24-hour charity stream we did
that that was like hard mode for me and
then everything afterwards was uh pretty
pretty like pretty easy because I
remember like I think dinosaur they were
telling me like the second day was like
tough yeah so like make sure there was
no dead air uh
anytime for like 13 hours right yeah
um so like they were really happy I
tried to like put as much of the
pressure off as possible
um but yeah it's just kind of like I
said after you like survived 24 hours of
sleep deprivation and then just like
constantly talking I Feel Like Anything
anything's possible yeah anything's
possible afterwards that's fair but yeah
I wouldn't want to do when I'm driving
because I want to be zoned out when I'm
driving you know yeah yeah I mean
especially when I because I you know
that's my first time ever driving a car
that big I think that's literally like
the limit of what the license allows in
Japan anything after that is just a
truck anything after that after you get
a different license yeah yeah there's
even like certain RVs I can't drive for
like I have to drive the smaller RVs and
the lighter ones right yeah because I
wanted to get a different RV initially
but it was slightly too heavy
um so I had to I had to get this one
um which is fine but it was really fun
to drive it like it was um because the
difference between like a car and an RV
is an RV you you're kind of like deeper
way more forward in the the RV so you'll
like there's pretty much no distance
between your feet and where the car ends
so you you can really clearly see where
where the car is like everywhere where
it's like with a long with a normal car
that's kind of like got a bigger uh
front it's like it's way harder to
figure out where the [__] the front of
the car is yeah especially like the that
corner or I guess food America could be
that corner
um so words
um but it was fun though because you get
like this panoramic view of the road
because you have these giant Windows to
all sides of you that you can see yeah
and there's giant mirrors and this the
dash cam uh the the yeah the behind you
Cam like the rear view cam is like on
this big screen it's really fun to drive
yeah scary on some roads but I got I
think I got pretty good at driving it by
the end yeah um I knew how to look like
a proper tracker yeah yeah you would
fully fully Embrace that role you just
needed the Hat yeah yeah the trucker had
you need the red ball and the pack
was like here it was when Conor was
driving and this uh the stream had
glitched so it looked like he just
removed his chin so it just gave Connor
like a [__] leafy chinway which is
like no Chin Connor
chocolate Corner
yeah that was my favorite outer context
clip but I'd say congratulations yeah
man thank you thank you appreciate it
very very well yeah very well I think
yeah I'll probably do another one at
some point in the future I'll probably
figure out how to make it better yeah
for sure there's definitely ways it can
be improved well what do you think about
how you can improve it
um I think having either uh another
additional person during the whole time
will rotate out more people
um is definitely a way to kind of make
sure that everyone can be more energetic
because it's it's demanding like yeah 13
hours every day is pretty tough for most
people yeah even like streamers
especially when you're doing stuff
Outdoors as well and you know you're
actually getting physical right yeah it
can be pretty demanding
um probably I don't know maybe I feel
like I'd have to stay in the RV but I
wouldn't make other people stay in the
RV I feel like did you stay in a hotel
is so much better because also like
showering was annoying like getting oh
yeah hot water was a commodity yeah I
don't think we had we had like no hot
water like any time like all the
campsites had freezing water yeah it was
just so cold it sucked so much
um definitely gotta find someone who
maybe understands the bag and the
streaming stuff more so you're not the
only table because it's like you know we
start this like the the morning prep is
like I wake up I have to get all this
bag stuff ready and stuff and it's like
well man I I wish I could just Shout
hour it's on the camera and we're going
right but it's like I have to get it
already you have to make sure
everything's charged make sure it's all
working right and then when you go to
bed when the stream ends sorry I have to
unplug everything make sure everything
everyone knows what to charge what and
just get everything ready before I can
start going to bed yeah so it's kind of
tough I'm just trying to think of how I
can make it better but it was really
really fun really successful I want to
do it again oh yeah